Halt das mal. – Einfach so? – Ja, einfach so.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein authentisches Doc Brown-Setting würde ich sagen.
Aber bei Blitzen muss man natürlich immeraufpassen. Ich habe gesagt aufpassen.
Tach zusammen, „Jack McPop“ hier. Heavy, ist
es wirklich schon so lange her?
Heute, vor gut 66 Jahren, ist Marty McFly aus dem Jahr
1955 zurück in die Zukunft gereist und zwar,
indem Doc Brown die Energie eines Gewitterblitzes
abgeleitet und in den DeLorean geschickt hat.
Ob das in Wirklichkeit funktionieren könnte, das
klären wir heute. Und ich freue mich mega,
denn meine beiden absoluten Lieblings-Podcaster sind
mit dabei – Nicolas Wöhrl und Reinhard Remfort.
100.000 Menschen hören Nicolas und Reinhard
bei ihrem Podcast „Methodisch inkorrekt!“zu.
Die beiden sind Physiker und stellen dort
brandheiße Forschung, Experimente oder kuriose
Gadgets vor. Das ist nicht nur spannend,
sondern auch verdammt witzig, vor allem,
wenn sie Schwurbel und Esoterik auseinandernehmen.
Das ist eine vernünftige Vorfahrt! Schön,dass Ihr da seid. Und Ihr habtdie Zeitmaschine mitgebracht.
Wie versprochen, da ist sie. Wenn Ihr eine Zeitmaschinehättet, wo würdet iIhr hinreißen?
1900! Da ist in der Wissenschaftsuper viel passiert.
Alles, was heute unsere
Gesellschaft bestimmt, Elektrizität… Hammer!
Pocken und Weltkriege okay, aber
Wissenschaft war cool zu der Zeit.
Ich würde es ein bisschen profaner
angehen. Ich habe mit 14 angefangen
Gitarre zu spielen. Ich glaube, ich würde mir
noch mal ein Nirvana-Konzert geben. Schön in
die 90er und dass noch mal miterleben.
Was würde Ihr denn machen, wenn Ihr
eine Zeitmaschine hättet? Was würdet Ihr Euch
angucken? Schreibt es mir mal in die Kommentare.
Bevor wir jetzt auf diese konkrete Blitzeszene
schauen, lassen uns mal auf den DeLoreanschauen
und wie Zeitreisen bei „Zurück
in die Zukunft“ überhaupt funktioniert.
Es gibt da diese Zeitschalt-Kreise, in denen
man einstellt wo man hinmöchte. Dann muss man
ordentlich aufs Gas drücken, 88mph braucht
der Mechanismus bis er funktioniert. Dassind umgerechnet…
140km/h!
Das ist innerorts schon ordentlich.
Es reicht aber immer noch nicht. Der essenzielle
Teil der Zeitmaschine ist der Fluxkompensator und
der wird im ersten Teil mit Plutonium betrieben.
Das klingt erst einmal sehr abwegig, so ein Ding
mit Plutonium zu betrieben, ist aber gar nicht soungewöhnlich.
In der Raumfahrt macht man das immer
noch, wenn man zum Beispiel eine Batterie braucht,
die lange hält und sehr zuverlässig ist.
Wenn man sich mal den Mars-Rover anguckt
oder die Voyager-Sonden, da hat man sogenannte
Radionuklidbatterien drin. Die nutzen die Energie,
also vor allem die Wärme des radioaktiven
Zerfalls und erzeugen damit Strom.
Ist nicht sehr effizient, 10% Wirkungsgrad
aber reicht halt für die Raumfahrt.
Und es hat ja auch funktioniert,
um Marty in die Vergangenheit zuschicken.
Aber dann hat er ein Problem. Esgibt dort eben kein Plutonium. Das heißt,
er braucht eine völlig neue Energiequelle,
um zurück in die Zukunft zu kommen.
Und genau da kommt die ikonische Rathausuhr
ins Spiel. Denn Marty weiß aus der Zukunft,
dass um präzise 22:04 Uhr ein Gewitterblitz in
diese Uhr einschlagen wird. Und genau den will er
dann mit Doc gemeinsam abfangen, um die Energie
des Blitzes in den Fluxkompensator zu leiten.
Weißt Du, was mich bei dem Film immer wahnsinnig
gemacht hat? Woher wissen wir eigentlich,
dass der Blitz exakt um 22:04 Uhr einschlägt
und nicht 22:04 Uhr und 22 Sekunden?
Keine Ahnung. Die Uhr muss ja auch
irgendwann wissen, wann es exakt 22:04Uhr ist.
Wahrscheinlich haben die in der Zukunft
reingeguckt und gesehen, wie die Zahnräder stehen
und dann vielleicht den Zeitpunkt festgelegt. Habt
Ihr eine Idee? Lasst mal einen Kommentar dazu da.
Selbst wenn wir wissen, wie viel Uhr genau der
Blitz da reingehauen ist, ist das das kleinsteProblem.
Also rein physikalisch. Wenn man sich
überhaupt einmal diese Route angucken, mit der der
Blitz abgefangen wird, die es höchstwahrscheinlich
auch Stahl und das ist nicht das Beste,
was man sich als elektrischen Leiter vorstellen
kann. Da werden wir Verluste ohne Ende haben,
Ohm’schen Widerstand bis zum geht nicht mehr, das
Ding wird heiß wie sonst was. Da gibt es besseres,
was man nehmen könnte.
Deswegen nimmt man für
normale Kabel beispielsweise Kupfer oder für
Hochspannungsleitungen nimmt man Aluminium.
Und wenn Ihr mal sehen wollt was passiert,
wenn ein Draht zu viel Strom abkriegt,
dann könnt Ihr mal in das Video reinschauen, was
wir letzten Sommer bei meinem Kumpel Cedric vom
Kanal Doktor Watson gedreht haben. Da haben
verschiedene YouTuber Experimente gemacht und
man sieht, wie ein Draht richtig in der Luft
verpufft. Wenn Ihr das noch mal genau sehenwollt,
den Link schreibe ich Euch in die Infobox.
- Das nächste Problem ist, das so ein Blitz
natürlich verhältnismäßig schnell ist. Er bewegt
sich mit einem Drittel der Lichtgeschwindigkeit;
also in einer Sekunde zweimal um den Erdball
rum. Deswegen ist es ziemlich unrealistisch,
wie wir im Film sehen, dass der Blitz so durch
das Kabel kriecht, langsam in Richtung Straße.
Man könnte natürlich schon ausrechnen, wann der
Blitz an der Straße angekommen ist.
Aber das ist nur ein relativ kleines Zeitfenster, in dem
Marty dann wirklich am Draht angekommen sein muss.
Und man bräuchte richtige Laborbedingungenund die haben die ja nicht.
Einfach richtig dreckig auf der Straße mit einem Fuß auf dem
Gaspedal. Also auch relativ dilettantisch,
der beschleunigt nicht gleichmäßig.
Und selbst wenn er das machen würde,
wäre das immer noch problematisch.
Ein Steinchen auf der Straße würde
schon reichen und dann passt das nicht mehr.
Also das Zeitfenster ist wirklich winzig.
Und wo wir gerade über den Versuchsaufbau
rummeckern. So wie Doc es gemacht hat,
wäre es vermutlich sein erstes und
letztes „Wetter-Experiment“ gewesen.
Weil er ans Kabel fasst?
- Ja, weil er ans Kabel fasst.
Offensichtlich ist dieses Kabel richtig beschissen
isoliert und ein Blitz hat gerne mal ein paar
tausend Ampere. Und jeder, der schon mal an
einen Weidezaun gepinkelt hat, weiß, dass dasweh tut.
Und ein Weidezaun hat nur 10Milliampere, da ist der abgeriegelt,
und 40-50 Milliampere sind für einen Menschen
tödlich. Vor allem, wenn die über das Herz laufen.
Und Doc macht es wunderbar. Hand
Nummer eins, Hand Nummer zwei.
Aber für den Fluxkompensator ist es ja
prinzipiell gut, denn der soll ja jede
Menge Energie abbekommen. Doc betont im Film ja
immer wieder, welche Leistung der ganz genau hat.
(1.21 Gigawatt!)
1.21 Gigawatt? Nicolas was heißt das genau?
Es heißt erstmal, dass Doc Zahlen falsch
ausspricht. Für so etwas würdest Du aus
der Grundlagenvorlesung rausfliegen. Es
müsste natürlich 1,21 Gigawatt heißen.
Und Watt ist die Einheit für Leistung – also
Energie pro Zeiteinheit, also Joule pro Sekunde.
Und 1,21 Gigawatt ist schon eine Hausnummer,
das ist ein durchschnittliches AKW.
Das heißt, dass da extrem viel Energie in extrem
kurzer Zeit durch den Fluxkompensator gehen muss.
Was können wir jetzt machen, um rauszukriegen,
ob der Blitz dafür ausreichen würde?
Wir müssen uns erst mal angucken, wie lange
der Blitz überhaupt am DeLorean anliegt?
Da gucken wir uns die entsprechenden
Szenen im Film an und sehen, dass der Blitz
ungefähr 0,5 Sekunden am DeLorean ist.
Und dann musst Du diese Zeit, die 0,5 Sekunden,
in die Formel für die Leistung einsetzen und
kannst ausrechnen, das ist ungefähr so viel wie
eine Person pro Monat verbraucht.
Die spannende Frage ist,
ob ein Blitz überhaupt so viel Energie hat?
Die gute Nachricht: theoretisch schon.
Wenn so ein Blitz entsteht, dann hat er ungefähr
eine Energie von 280 Kilowattstunden.
Das ist erstmal deutlich mehr als unser Fluxkompensator
braucht. Die schlechte Nachricht ist allerdings,
von diesen 280 Kilowattstunden, die rein
theoretisch zur Verfügung stehen würden,
kommt nur ein Bruchteil unten an. Also das
meiste davon geht unterwegs verloren oder
wird besser gesagt umgesetzt. Unten ankommen etwa
10%, so 16 Kilowattstunden. Und das reicht nicht.
Und das können wir Euch sogar zeigen,
denn Ihr habt Experimente mitgebracht!
Genau! Also wo diese Verluste zum Tragen
kommen können wir Euch zum Beispiel hiermitzeigen.
Das ist eine Influenzmaschine.Damit können wir Blitze erzeugen.
Reinhard dreht am Rad und dadurch erzeugt er
eine Spannung und die Spannung entlädt sich
dann oben an diesen Kugeln in Blitzen.
Und Ihr hört schon dieses knallen.
Da werden Schallwellen erzeugt und
Schallwellen bedeuten natürlich,
dass Energie verloren geht. Und Ihr seht es auch
leuchten – das ist ionisiertes Gas. Das ist einPlasma.
Und auch da wird viel Energie verbraucht. Und diese ionisierte Luft können wir Euch noch ein
bisschen besser zeigen. Da haben wir nämlich
noch ein zweites Experiment mitgebracht.
Das was wir hier haben ist ein
Tesla-Transformator.
Das besteht aus zwei Spulen und dadurch werden hier im
oberen Bereich sehr hohe Spannungen erzeugt.
Hier sehen wir auch wieder Blitzentladungen.
Also das Plasma, was sich hier bildet,
und wo Energie verloren geht.
16 Kilowattstunden klingt ein bisschenmickrig,
aber bei Blitzen muss man natürlich
immer aufpassen. Ich habe gesagt aufpassen.
Also diese kleinen Blitze reichen, um
einen Physiker glücklich zu machen.
Aber wenn es wirklich um Zeitreisen geht, muss man
natürlich sagen, dass die 16 Kilowattstunden,
über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, nicht
ausreichen, um durch die Zeit zu reisen.
Da bräuchte man schon ein paar Blitze mehr, 10 etwa.
- 10 Blitze hätte Marty gebraucht? Holy Shit!
Damit steckt er im Jahr 1955 fest. Und wir
können festhalten, so wie im Film präsentiert
funktioniert das nicht. Ein Gewitterblitz
in der Rathausuhr reicht leider nicht aus.
Im Film hat es dann aber geklappt, Marty kommt
zurück in die Zukunft. Und auch, wenn das bei
uns jetzt nicht so ganz funktionieren würde –
Nicolas, Reinhard, wir lieben den Film. Also wenn
wir jetzt ein Tribut an Doc Brown machen wollen.
Gibt es denn Möglichkeiten, wie das theoretisch
auch in Wirklichkeit funktionieren könnte?
- Die ganz große Herausforderung ist eigentlich
die Energiespeicherung und das ist eine
Herausforderung, an der gerade sehr
aktuell geforscht wird. Da geht es natürlich
um unterschiedliche Szenarien. Es geht nicht
nur darum, beispielsweise deinen Handy-Akku besser
zu machen, auch wichtig. Aber vor allem geht esdarum,
viel Energie zu speichern, beispielsweise
aus der Windkraft, wenn mal Windflaute ist.
Und genau da haben wir jetzt wieder ein Problem
bei der Zeitreise, weil wir brauchen ja sehr
schnell sehr, sehr viel Energie. Und wenn wir
uns mal die Standard-Akkus angucken, die besten
die wir kennen, die wir in unseren Handys haben,
Lithium-Ionen-Akkus. Die können zwar schon sehr
viel Energie speichern, aber die Energie kriegt
man da weder schnell rein noch schnell raus.
Also so einen Akku direkt an die Steckdose
hängen ist zum Beispiel keine gute Idee.
An Blitze? – Nein!
Der Film macht uns noch einen Vorschlag,
was denn eine Lösung sein könnte, zumindest im
Englischen. Da heißt der Fluxkompensator nämlich
„Flux capacitor“. Also „Fluss Kondensator“
- Kondensatoren sind elektrische Bauteile.
Im einfachsten Fall kann man sich das als zwei
Platten vorstellen, die einfach gegenüberstehen,
die man elektrisch aufladen kann, indem man
eine Spannung anschließt. Die eine Platte
lädt sich positiv, die andere negativ und wenn
man die Spannungsquelle trennt,
bleibt diese Ladung erhalten. Und die kann man wieder abrufen.Also man kann Energie darin speichern. Das ist
eigentlich auch genau das, was wir haben wollen.
Denn diese Aufladung geht superschnell und das
Entladen geht auch wieder unglaublich schnell. Und
das ist genau das, was wir hier eigentlich habenmöchten.
Es gibt nur ein winzig kleines Problem.
Denn die Energie, die man in so einem Kondensator
speichern kann, ist nicht besonders groß.
Also wir müssten schon einen unglaublich
großen Kondensator bauen, um damit
genug Strom auf die Kette zu bekommen.
Jetzt habe ich noch gelesen, es
gibt auch noch Superkondensatoren.
Was macht diese super oder besser?
- Die sind ein bisschen anders aufgebaut als die
Kondensatoren, über die Reinhard gerade gesprochen
hat. Da war zwischen den Elektrodenplatten ein Dielektrikum.
Bei den Superkondensatoren haben wir ein Elektrolyt dazwischen.
Das ist im Wesentlichen eine feste oder flüssige Phase,wo Ionen durchfließen können. Und die leiten denStrom.
Das sind Details aber das Entscheidende ist
eigentlich, die haben eine höhere Energiedichte
und die haben eine höhere Kapazität.
Aber das klingt doch dann,  als wäre das die perfekte Lösung, oder?
Ja, langsam. Das Problem liegt bei der Energiedichte,
über die wir gerade schon gesprochen haben. Die ist nämlich selbst
bei diesen Superkondensatoren immer noch relativ
gering. Die liegt 10 Wattstunden pro Kilogramm.
Das heißt, selbst wenn Du nur einen einzigen
Blitz speichern wollen würdest bräuchtest Du
1.600 Kilogramm Kondensator-Material.
Dann haben wir noch das Problem,
das so ein Blitz ein paar Millionen Volt mit sich
bringt. Und sagen wir mal so:
Der Superkondensatoran sich mag das jetzt auch nicht so gerne. Damüssten wir uns auch etwas überlegen, wie wir das
so schnell mit der hohen Spannung da reinkriegen.
- Okay, aber wenn Doc Brown diese 1.600 Kilogramm
Kondensator-Material irgendwie im Keller gehabt
hätte, wäre es dann irgendwie möglich gewesen?
Schwierig. Superkondensatoren, patentiert 1957,
so richtig kommerziell erfolgreich erst in den
1990er Jahren. Also mit Superkondensatoren
wird es wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Aber wir entwickeln ja immer neue Dinge. Wir
forschen immer weiter, und es gibt Hoffnung.
Und wenn es jetzt nicht zwingend
darum geht, das 1955 zu machen,
sondern heute oder in 50 Jahren oder in 100 Jahren
oder so, dann gibt es noch ein paar Alternativen.
Eine davon wären zum Beispiel supraleitende
magnetische Energiespeicher. Da wird Energie
im Magnetfeld gespeichert und kann auf
einen Schlag wieder abgerufen werden.
Und wie kann ich mir das vorstellen?
- Es gibt gewisse Materialien,
sogenannte supraleitende Materialien, in
denen sinkt der elektrische Widerstand auf 0,
wenn man sie stark genug herunter kühlt. Und wenn
man so ein Material hat, kann man das so bauen,
dass man einen Strom da drin hat, den man auf
eine Kreisbahn zwingt, der dann da ohne Widerstand
für immer quasi fließen kann, solange es
runtergekühlt ist. Und Strom, der im Kreis fließt,
erzeugt ein Magnetfeld. Und in diesem Magnetfeld
kann man Energie speichern. Da kann man quasi ohne
Verlust speichern und auch wieder abrufen.
Und warum muss das gekühlt werden?
Weil generell bei Materialien der elektrische
Widerstand sinkt, wenn sie runtergekühltwerden.
Und bei supraleitenden Materialien
ist das Besondere, das er auf 0 sinkt.
Aber generell ist es bei allen Materialien so, dass der
elektrische Widerstand sinkt, wenn man sie stark
genug runterkühlt. Und das können wir auch zeigen.
Wir haben hier ein Kupferrohr mitgebracht,
also ein ganz normales, ziemlich dickes
Kupferrohr. Und das ist hohl von innen.
Wenn wir da jetzt etwas durchwerfen, zum Beispiel
dieses Aluminiumstückchen, dann fällt das,
wie du es erwarten würdest, relativ einfach
durch. Nichts Besonderes. Das ändert sich,
wenn wir einen Magneten durchwerfen. Also es
ist immer noch das normale Kupferrohr.
Hier klebt erstmal nichts. Aber wenn wir den Magneten
durchwerfen, entsteht ein Wirbelstrom. Und dieser
Wirbelsturm bremst den Magneten im Fallen. Das
kann man zum einen natürlich gleich beobachten…
Ist es schwer?
- Ja, es ist schwer!
Das kann man natürlich beobachten, weil es
langsamer fällt. Aber wir sehen hier auch,
wir haben eine besondere Folie aufgeklebt,
die zeigt Dir das Magnetfeld.
Ich lasse den Magneten mal fallen.
Fast als hätten wir die Zeit angehalten.
Das ist schon krass. Und noch krasser wird es,
wenn wir das Ganze jetzt noch runterkühlen
und zwar auf -196°C, oder 80K besser gesagt.
Dafür haben wir hier flüssigen Stickstoff!
Halt das mal…
Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein authentisches
Doc. Brown-Setting würde ich sagen.
Es ist auch tatsächlich nicht so schlimm.
Man kann da auch… Nicht nachmachen!
Das tauchen wir jetzt rein. Das muss ein bisschen längerdrinbleiben als deine Finger.
Das haben wir jetzt runtergekühlt. Es brodelt
auf jeden Fall immer noch und jetzt wiederholen
wir das Experiment von gerade. Wir werfen
wieder den Magneten rein und beobachten,
wie lange der Magnet jetzt fällt.
Das ist schon deutlich länger, jetzt
schon. Dadurch, dass es jetzt kalt ist,
kann der Strom viel besser fließen. Und
dadurch hält das Magnetfeld viel länger.
Und wir sehen, ist das schon beachtlich.
Total. Also mehr als doppelt
so lange auf jeden Fall.
Man könnte Magnetfelder so
sehr lange aufrechterhalten. Das Problem
ist nur, man muss sie halt runterkühlen.
Und das wäre ein krasser technischer
Aufwand. Was sagt ihr? Wäre das eine
Chance für Doc Brown in der Zukunft?
- Ja, vielleicht. Man arbeitet sehr daran,
supraleitenden Materialien zu finden,
die auch bei Raumtemperatur supraleitendsind.
Leider sind wir da aber noch nicht.
Also braucht es doch ein bisschen Zeit,
damit das funktioniert. Und dann wäre das in einer Zukunft, in die wir zurückreisen, vielleicht eine Möglichkeit.
Fassen wir zusammen.
Ein Blitz hätte theoretisch genug Energie, um den Fluxkompensator zu betreiben. Aber leider kommt davon nicht genug
bei uns auf der Erde an. Wir bräuchten 10 Blitze.
Und selbst, wenn wir die hätten, bräuchten wir
eine ziemlich fancy Speichertechnologie,
damit Zeitreisen irgendwie funktioniert.
Niclas, Reinhard vielen, vielen Dank
fürs erklären. Und Dank geht auch raus
an die Inspirator, Zentrum für mathematische,
naturwissenschaftliche Bildung hier in Leipzig.
Die haben uns die Tesla-Spule geliehen.
Die Fakultät für Chemie hat uns flüssigen
Stickstoff gegeben und die Fakultät für Physik hat
uns die Influenzmaschine gegeben. Also 1.000 Dank,
Link zu denen packe ich Euch in die Infobox und
natürlich auch den Link zu „Methodisch inkorrekt!“
denn Ihr habt nächstes Jahr was vor, oder?
- 2022 wollen wir wieder auf Tour gehen. Und da
wird, unter anderem, der DeLorean und „Back
to the Future“ wieder eine Rolle spielen.
Und bis dahin kann ich Euch auf jeden Fall den
Podcast empfehlen. Hört auf jeden Fall mal rein
und schreibt mir bitte in die Kommentare, wie
Ihr diese Folge fandet. Vergesst auf gar keinen
Fall aber diesen Kanal zu abonnieren und die
Glocke zu drücken. Dann können wir uns ganz
bald wiedersehen. Ich würde mich freuenund Euch beiden wünsche ich jetzt sehrviel Spaß beim Zeitreisen.
(Ich bin froh, dass Marty so viele
Schichten übereinander anhat.
Shirt, Hemd, Jeansjacke und Weste.
Das hilft uns heute extrem.)